fully wireless earbuds are quickly
becoming the new standard for listening
to music or basically anything else
now that we're getting into 2021 and
beyond
so in this video we're gonna compare the
three
best pairs of fully wireless earbuds to
see which ones are the best for each use
case we've got apple's incredibly
popular airpods pro for 250
or actually on sale right now on amazon
for 197
we've got sony's brand new wf
wf-1000xm4s that are known for having
the best noise cancellation
which are priced at a pretty high 278
dollars
and we've got samsung's new galaxy buds
pro
for 200 or currently on sale for only
170 on amazon
less expensive than the other two so
without further ado let's get right into
comparing these earbuds in a bunch of
different categories
starting with the size and the
portability of the cases
the case on the galaxy buds pro is
actually the smallest in terms of the
footprint
but it's a lot thicker than the airpods
pro and surprisingly
the sony's are not only the largest but
also the
thickest as well but it is a huge
improvement
over last year's xm3s in terms of the
weight of the cases themselves
the airpods case is actually the
heaviest
compared to the surprisingly light sony
case now for design
and build quality because the sony's are
so lightweight
the case feels a little bit cheap
because of the matte plastic feel
that doesn't seem as solid now the
galaxy buds are a small step
up and the airpods pro case does seem to
have the best build quality
and design now in terms of the quality
of the hinges the airpods pro case has a
very solid
metal hinge that feels very nice to
flick open
with a pretty strong magnet holding the
case closed
and unfortunately the sony's have the
weakest magnet and therefore have the
highest chance
of opening if it falls on top of that
both the galaxy buds pro and the sonys
have plastic hinges that don't feel as
nice and cause the top of the cases
to wiggle especially on the sony's
now in terms of how much battery life is
packed into the cases themselves
excluding the earbuds the airpods pro
case holds enough power to give you
19 more hours of listening time with
noise cancellation on
while the sony's give you 16 more hours
and the galaxy buttons pro give you an
extra 13 hours
and what's great this year is that all
of these earbuds support wireless
charging
whereas in last year's comparison only
the airpods pro had it however the
airpods pro case uses
lightning to charge which is a bit
disappointing
compared to usbc on the other two now
opening up the cases both
the airpods pro and the sony's feel very
satisfying when you're taking them out
and putting them back into the case with
a very strong magnetic feel
but on the galaxy but pro the magnetic
connection is
very weak so it takes very little effort
to take them out
and that causes them to fall out very
easily
compared to the other two that fit very
snugly now before we get into comparing
the audio quality between these wireless
earbuds
let's compare some of the fine details
of the earbuds themselves
the airpods pro have a very sleek low
profile shape
with a short stem sticking out for
better microphone quality
and because of the stem the airpods look
quite a bit smaller than the other two
especially the very large and bulbous
sonys now in terms of the weight of the
earbuds themselves
the airpods pro are by far the lightest
with the sony's being the heaviest
as expected due to the size and that's
probably why they also get the best
battery life by far eight hours per bud
with anc on
compared to just 4.5 hours on the
airpods pro
and five hours with the galaxy butts pro
in terms of the design
they honestly look really nice and clean
but i don't really like the
chrome-like reflective finish on the
galaxy but pro
which can gather fingerprints or smudges
the airpods pro look very classy and
simple
with the glossy white plastic design but
the sony's
i would say look by far the most premium
or professional
with a nice matte finish and clean
design elements
now in terms of comfort in the ears the
airpods pro are by far the most
comfortable out of the three
and there's two very good reasons for it
while both the sony's and galaxy buds
pro have a hard plastic tube
that enters your ear canal with the
sony's tube
being quite a bit longer the earpods pro
actually have a completely flush speaker
grill
so the only thing that goes into your
ear canal is the very soft
silicone ear tip and the sony's actually
come with foam ear tips
that you have to squish like earplugs
each
and every time you want to put them in
your ears which i've got to say is
extremely annoying because i found
myself
taking them out multiple times to squish
them down even further
compared to the other earbuds that
simply pop right in
on top of that all of these earbuds
create a seal inside of your ears for
better bass
sound quality and noise cancellation but
the earpods pro
actually have a vent that releases the
air pressure within your
ear and while the galaxy buds pro say
they have a vent and they do
it doesn't really seem to do that much
and the sony's don't really offer
anything like that at all
so your ears end up feeling the most
plugged now on top of that because of
the very large size of the sony xm4s it
kind of puts
pressure on your ears combined with the
expanding foam
that also puts a bit of pressure on the
inside of your ear canals
so overall the airpods pro feel
absolutely the most comfortable thanks
to the softer ear tip design the venting
feature
and the lighter weight now getting into
sound quality
the galaxy buds pro are the only ones
that actually come with two speakers in
each earbud
a woofer and a tweeter and because of
that they have a ton of bass
while also having very bright highs due
to the tweeters
but unfortunately they are really
lacking in the mids
which leads to vocals not really
sounding natural at all
and overall not as well balanced sound
now for the airpods pro
they do very well in terms of the mids
with vocal sounding super clean
full and natural the bass definitely
isn't as heavy as the buds pro
but it's very tight and accurate and
overall the airpods pro are actually
louder
than the butts pro which makes them even
more impressive and now
for the sonys they absolutely killed it
in my opinion
now the volume definitely isn't as loud
as the earpods pro
especially in the high notes which i do
miss
but the overall sound quality is
incredible vocals sound perfect
being natural just like on the airpods
pro but with the sonys
there seems to be the most separation
between sound frequencies
so it sounds very clean whereas with the
airpods pro
some of the frequencies kind of clash
together just a little bit
and i've got to say that the sound stage
feels the widest on the sony's as well
and out of all of these earbuds the
sonys give you bass
that's very deep loud punchy and
accurate
all at the same time so overall they're
very well balanced compared to the
airpods pro
that seem to be heavy on the high notes
and the galaxy buds pro that are greatly
lacking
in terms of the mids so yeah the sony's
definitely have the best sound quality
now in terms of noise cancellation
the galaxy butts pro are by far the
worst with the airpods pro being a nice
step
up and the sony's completely destroying
the other two
getting rid of more noise but in terms
of the ambient or transparency modes
the airpods pro absolutely kill it here
with everything like vocals and noises
sounding almost exactly like it does
without having anything at all in your
ears
which is extremely impressive now with
the galaxy buds and the sonys
the ambient modes don't work nearly as
well making your voice sound a bit
muted and other people's voices don't
sound very natural at all
like they do with the airpods pro now
before we get into which buds we
recommend
i want to go through a couple of the
feature and software differences
the galaxy buds pro have ipx 7 water
resistance
much better than ipx4 on the other two
and out of all of them
the airpods pro were also the most
reliable
basically always staying connected to my
iphone while the other two would
occasionally disconnect out of nowhere
for a split second the sony's actually
require you to download their headphone
connect app
to use the earbuds but it crashed on me
a few times
and the initial software update took
forever
over 30 minutes which was very annoying
but the beauty about the airpods pro is
that they don't require anything at all
no apps no software updates they just
connect
instantly if you have an iphone so you
don't even have to go into the bluetooth
menu
and on top of that they automatically
sync to the rest of your apple devices
that are logged into your apple id
which is super convenient for apple
users and on top of that
i prefer these stem controls much better
than the touch controls on the others
because touch can be kind of unreliable
at times and when you for example
double tap on them to skip tracks they
kind of push the earbuds further into
your ears
which can get very annoying especially
since the sony's kind of hurt your ears
after a while
compared to the airpods where you simply
squeeze the stem
and now finally let's get into which
earbuds we recommend for each use case
the galaxy butts pro are definitely the
least expensive
sitting at 170 on sale right now or 200
retail but they just don't sound nearly
as good
as either the airpod pros or the sony's
and on top of that the noise
cancellation and ambient noise features
were by far
the worst out of the bunch but due to
the compact design of the earbuds
and the ipx7 water resistance they could
be great for someone who likes to work
out
or maybe even swim the sony's definitely
have the best sound quality
and the best noise cancellation but
you're gonna be paying 278 dollars for
them
and they also aren't nearly as
comfortable as the airpods pro
yes the earbuds themselves do have the
best battery life but your ears honestly
start hurting after a while
because of the very large size that sort
of squeezes into your ear
and the foam tips that expand putting
pressure on your ear canals
but with the airpods pro the tubeless
soft
ear tip design is incredible for comfort
along with the venting feature
that gets rid of pressure in your ears
and the lightweight design
that lets you listen to them for hours
and the airpods pro
are by far the most reliable because
they basically never glitch out or
disconnect
like the other sometimes do they don't
require any setup or software updates or
downloads
and they fit perfectly into the apple
ecosystem
for iphone users they just work right
out of the box
and they work very well but if you're
all about having the absolute
best sound quality or the best active
noise cancellation
then i would say that spending the extra
cash on the sony's
is definitely worth the price especially
if you're an android user
but if you're okay with sacrificing some
of the sound quality and anc
performance to get absolutely incredible
comfort
convenience reliability better
transparency mode and a much lower 200
price tag on amazon right now then i
would honestly just go for the airpods
pro and as long as the airpods pro are
on sale
i honestly wouldn't recommend the galaxy
but pro
because you have to compromise in so
many different areas
so there you guys have it hopefully this
video helped you make a decision
and if it did feel free to use our links
down below to the best deals on these
earbuds
and if you enjoyed the video go ahead
and click the circle about to subscribe
for more videos like this one
definitely check out one of these two
right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in
the next video